i'm tom chalu i'm sandra smith i'm steve
ducey and this is the fox news rundown
friday march 11th 2022
i'm dave anthony it's two years to the
day since coven was declared a pandemic
and the virus may never go away i can
guarantee you we are going to see an
increase in covet cases this fall this
coming fall why because cobit 19 is
going to behave like the other
respiratory viruses that circulate every
single year
and lisa brady record high gas prices
aren't just a pain at the pump they have
a widespread impact on other costs
including for restaurants i mean today i
bought everything from french fries to
hush puppy mix
and it all plays into
moving it from point a to point b
and i'm carol markowitz i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
it's now been two years since the world
health organization proclaimed kovite 19
can be
characterized as a pandemic later that
same day march 11th president trump
addressed the nation we will ultimately
and expeditiously defeat this virus he
added europe to his china travel ban and
we have
issued guidance on school closures
social distancing and reducing large
gatherings and then of course came all
the political battles over coveted
restrictions zoom classrooms masks and
vaccines and mandates
but back to that day
listen to the coveted numbers the head
of the w.h.o dr tedros gabriele cited
more than 118 000 cases
and 4291
people have lost their lives we've now
topped six million covert deaths almost
a million of them here in the us and
more than 452 million infections
globally it was really remarkable that
was the tip of the iceberg dr marty
mccary is a professor at johns hopkins
university and a fox news contributor
yeah if you think about the proportion
of the population
that's died from this infection
it is
relatively similar to what we've seen in
other pandemics in history
if you take for example in mississippi
one in 200 adults have died from the
covet 19 pandemic
so it should be a reminder
of how we need to have systems
to be prepared and to move quickly so
the number one lesson i think over the
last two years is we got to have our own
american scientists on the ground doing
doing research quickly so we can get
answers
we didn't have a vaccine of course two
years ago that came a year later now we
have about three quarters of us adults
fully vaccinated
and of those about almost half have had
boosters
what about those who are unvaccinated
now still two years in
most of them have immunity from natural
immunity from prior infection
but we have studied this at johns
hopkins and if you think you had covet
but have never had a documented positive
test you can't rely on thinking you had
it you really need to have documentation
in order to trust that immunity to some
degree
there are people who are still
non-immune who are getting infected and
getting into deep trouble they are older
people with multiple risk factors and
they've not been vaccinated and they
haven't had the infection they're still
showing up at the hospital albeit at a
slower rate we're also seeing a little
bit of an uptick right now in the uk
which tends to be a preview of what to
expect in the us
and what we're seeing there is that
older people particularly in lower
vaccinated regions where we think the
booster utilization rate is lower in
older people there's coming into the
hospital we're seeing a bit of an uptick
in new hospitalizations there
cases have gone down a lot here in the
us since the record omicron wave that we
had in december in january but when you
look at these waves when you look at the
graph on your johns hopkins covet 19
dashboard you can see we had that spike
up in the spring of 2020 went down
summer back up down then fall and winter
into 2021 we had a record at that time
of cases then it went down
president biden declared independence
from culver around july 4th and then
boom we got hit by delta and then boom
we got hit by omicron
are we
going to have another wave in your view
at some point as we get to summer as we
get to fall and winter probably not the
likes of which we've seen over the last
two years
i can guarantee you we are going to see
an increase in covet cases this fall
this coming fall why because
covet 19 is going to behave like the
other respiratory viruses that circulate
every single year now anything is
possible we can see an outbreak among an
animal species where we believe in the
animal kingdom there's a reservoir a
virus that can replicate and mutate and
then cross over to humans that's
possible but as of now i don't think
there's anything we need to worry about
in terms of another surge the likes of
which we just went through
covet is going to be like our flu and
cold right we just deal with it every
year
so this cover 19 virus has a stigma for
good reasons we've been burned living
through the last two years but let's
remember there's a host of respiratory
viruses that we have to learn to live
with and what i mean by that is some
basic principles if you are exposed to
someone wear a high quality mask for a
period of time
if you are sick stay home and if you're
around someone vulnerable be careful the
other day the cdc director told us we
can put our masks in a drawer hawaii
will be the last state to get rid of
mandates later this month democratic
governor david ige says we care about
our community and we are all willing to
sacrifice to keep each other healthy and
safe but florida governor ron desantis a
republican who fought against mandates
tells fox it is political theater
they're doing it for the appearance
they're not doing it because it's having
any meaningful medical impact what does
dr mccary think about the future for
masking you look at what was happening
in asia they got burned by
sars in the past and they've had other
outbreaks before we've really had to
deal with them they highly encourage and
it's well accepted that if there's an
active outbreak almost everybody will be
wearing a mask in a public indoor
setting
and if you have any risk factor you may
choose to want to wear one yourself and
if you've been around someone who's had
the infection and you're concerned
you'll wear one so i think we'll see
that sort of selective masking policy
live on the problem is
the worst thing you can do at public
health is insist on something beyond
when it's necessary and we've done that
we're doing it right now with cloth
masks and kids
low quality mask almost of no benefit
and we're asking kids to wear it beyond
the period when the infection has
passed through the area so which what
we're doing is we're polarizing people
around a public health intervention that
could be effective in the future
you talk about kids there's been a lot
of focus also on the mental strain for
them
also for adults i mean this this
pandemic has taken a toll on on the
psychology of a lot of americans and and
and you know people were staying at home
they were working at home for a long
time and it's not easy to necessarily go
back to normal with a flick of a switch
how big a deal in your opinion is the
mental aspect of covet i think it's a
huge deal and i think it's one we're
going to have a lot of regrets about
because
we put the entire country on this
mission
to stop all virus transmission at any
cost
and the reality is people don't just die
from viral replication they die
from hopelessness
and from poverty and from a sense of
their livelihoods being taken away
so we saw
a
30 000
death increase
in substance abuse in year one of the
pandemic we don't have the numbers for
year two yet
we are seeing suicides that can only be
explained by kids being shut out of
school
and we're seeing cognitive delays and
declines talk to a speech pathologist
talk to a high school guidance counselor
we're seeing now problems that we're
just beginning to understand for example
in baltimore city where i practice
medicine
there were a number of kids when the
schools went virtual
that never logged on
and then when the schools went in person
they never showed up these are children
lost to the system entirely
under the fallacy that oh you know you
can learn virtually and it'll be okay
we've got to find those people and
rescue them
there was a lot of talk also about
something that people have not fully
understood and that's the long haul
there are long haulers people who didn't
really get over covid i was talking to a
co-worker who said they were speaking to
somebody who still can't taste
after getting covered months later so
that aspect of it is it still a mystery
to you or are you learning more
no it's still a mystery i think to most
physicians we have seen long-haul
symptoms after other infections
if you look at dengue fever or even
influenza
we know that those long-haul symptoms
are proportional to how severe and how
long you were sick with the virus
and we see them also
in children with covid for example the
long-haul symptoms are identical to that
seen with other viruses that's been
studied and published in the lancet we
don't really know what's happening
there's a theory that your antibodies
are maybe crossing over and maybe
attacking some of the neurologic system
there is really no effective treatment
that i've heard of and i've asked a lot
of people and there's a lot of money
being thrown at it in my opinion we
probably won't get much out of that
investment in research we did learn
especially in omicron
that being vaccinated certainly wasn't
the shield we'd hoped
that people still got coveted it wasn't
as strong and it was milder but you
still got infected
are we in for more rounds of boosters in
your view over the course of years to
come
it really depends on the variants that
come about for so for example
let's say that a new variant is
discovered next fall or in three years
both are very possible scenarios we may
see that the current immunity
works a little bit that gives you some
partial protection
but that for those particularly high
risk
namely older folks
that a
variant specific booster may really
protect them i don't think it's the
influenza model where you come in every
year for a
seasonal specific strain
but regardless whatever we deal with in
the future
we are in your view
we should
live
more of a normal way we did even before
the pandemic and just deal with covet as
it comes is that the way it should be
from now forward the second we heard
hear about a new virus
we've got to move our
researchers immediately to study it not
just in the lab but study the
epidemiology statistics that is who's
dying what are the risk factors
um how long
are you contagious for when are you
shedding the virus the most
do masks work is it surface transmission
or is it aerosolized
those are basic clinical research
experiments we did not do with covet
early on and as a result we debated
those answers for months even for some
over the entire two year period we still
don't have the exact origin of this
outbreak we know came out of china and
woohound
do you think we'll ever know i think we
have as much information now as we will
ever have but we're not going to
discover a scrap lab notebook in the
wuhan lab if we send our people over
there we're not going to get a
confession from a lab worker who's
willing to risk the lives of their
entire family back in china
and as i told harris faulkner in april
of 2020 at the beginning of the pandemic
it was an infected lab worker that was
patient zero that went over to the wuhan
hospital five miles away and got treated
that was the epicenter it's very obvious
everything points to that there's been
other viral lab leaks in china in the
past
and so i think we have all the
information we're going to need to have
people want to know
the origins to have closure we've lost a
tremendous amount of lives worldwide and
people want a sense of closure dr marty
mccary johns hopkins professor fox news
contributor author the price we pay what
broke american health care and how to
fix it as always great to talk to you
thank you
good to be with you dave thank you
[Music]
this is carol markowitz with your fox
news commentary coming up
inflation has hit a 40-year high again
consumer prices up nearly 8 percent for
the twelve months ending in february and
that does not include the most recent
surge in gas prices which were up 38
percent year-over-year but have spiked
more as the fighting continues in
ukraine yes it is accurate that the
invasion by president putin into ukraine
has impacted global inflation inflation
in the united states though white house
spokeswoman jen sakhi continues to get
pushback from republicans who say the
president's policies have also fueled
inflation the bottom line is more pain
for consumers as the cost of just about
everything goes up and that's true for
restaurants too like taco chain buena
onda dealing with the rising cost of
avocados when it gets too expensive i
think people are just not going to buy
it we can't sell a bowl of guacamole for
twenty dollars as of december the labor
department showed higher costs for
eating at home were slightly outpacing
the rising cost of eating away from home
but high inflation is yet another
challenge for an industry that had
enough on its plate already after two
years of pandemic restrictions it's
definitely impacting i do the buying a
retail market a wholesale operation and
a 300 seat restaurant ted hammerman is
better known as mr fish which is the
name of his business a fish market and
restaurant in myrtle beach south
carolina and then i'm also partnered up
with another fellow and we import full
container loads of
seafood products from vietnam from
tunisia i was in tunisia in november and
october
the reason for that is to fill in the
gaps because you know seafood's global
and
we have a very limited resource in
america we're also very smart with
controlling and quoting
our resources
so i'm guessing that fish is really
sort of the biggest item in your
itinerary when you go shopping if you
will for all of your businesses
so
can you give us an example of you know
this much fish used to cost this and now
it's costing this
last summer on an average
on fresh fish i was buying between 20
and
25 000 of fresh fish a week
now that same amount of finch
has gone up
across the board
dollar fifty to two dollars a pound
the freight last year was 30 cent a
pound now it's 33 cents a pound
and it's gonna go up to a half a buck
very very soon
so when you say freight are you talking
about because i'm thinking also about
you've got transportation costs as well
correct
well sure and then you got to keep in
mind if you buy a grouper
and me as a wholesaler i'm paying eight
bucks a pound for that grouper that's a
whole round grouper gutted and on ice
fresh coming out of florida or costa
rica or even locally if it's uh
below charleston then we put it on a
freight truck you're still going to pay
33 cent a pound when it hits your dock
you just made eight dollars and 33 cents
a pound
when you cut that fish and you throw
half of them away because only half is
usable because in america we don't eat
the heads as other countries do
so i got 16 and 66 cents a pound
in that fish in that filet
before i pay labor before i pay electric
overhead
and uh all the other miscellaneous taxes
that i pay so yeah we want to be
sustainable as well as a business so to
do that you got no one to hold them
knowing to hold them you gotta roll to
punches and uh freight is
you know years back freight was eh it
costs a dime a pound no biggie you know
you can eat that
now
it's an integral part of your business
so
i mean today i bought everything from
french fries to hush puppy mix and it
all plays into
moving it from point a to point b
right so you're saying that's affecting
not just the transportation of the fish
but it's being folded into higher prices
for really everything that you're buying
and really granted the fisherman when he
goes out
for instance
the fishermen we're in a bay long bay
so it's 30 miles before they can't even
think about wetting a hook
and
they're burning
x amount of fuel to get to where they
need to start fishing
now that fuel costs them a dollar more a
gallon and it's going up on a daily
basis
so it all gets figured into that
equation where that eight dollar fish
by
i would suggest if this keeps on going
the way it is will be nine dollars in a
couple weeks
so is this what your distributors are
saying to you that it's really the gas
prices having the biggest impact or were
you already seeing these prices for
everything from the fish to the french
fries
rising
even before the gas gas prices really
started to spike
well it's caused that hysteria and
it's caused that opportunity for profit
making too
so
i mean in some cases it's definitely
it's warranted it's costing more
wow are you concerned that rising gas
prices and inflation in general is going
to make people less likely to go out to
eat in order to save money
it causes other things to rise i mean
beef we sell beef as well
beef is a prime example as soon as the
pump started going up the beef prices
went up were they given to farmers
anymore that's very debatable
and uh
if you look at jbs
which is the biggest meat producer
almost in the world actually because
they're they're in europe but they're
based in iowa
i mean they've had such corporate
profits
i mean they've handed out the executive
board just
they all bought super yachts you know
they're farting in silk as they say meat
is one of the industries the white house
has singled out suggesting too much
power for a handful of companies is one
driver of high prices and when he
announced a ban on russian energy this
week president biden blamed rising gas
prices on putin's war but he had this
message for oil and gas companies and
their financial backers it's no excuse
to exercise excessive price increases or
padding profits or any kind of effort to
exploit this situation for restaurants
this inflation wave could be crushing
after so many pandemic disruptions from
the initial round of shutdowns through
the delta and omicron surges after what
felt like a promising spring last year
that was pretty bad the restaurant
really suffered we closed it but the
market did extremely well because people
didn't want to go to restaurants but you
know they wanted to
satiate that urge for a fried oyster we
make a
fried green tomato soft crab tower
and they say oh man i wish i had that so
they'll call in and to go order and
they'll come pick it up or we'll bring
it out to their car
masked up and gloved up
so yeah
through the eyes of adversity then go i
how much
more
can you
as a businessman take if the prices of
what you're buying continues to go up if
your distributors continue to charge
more
that's a good point
these are inflationary times like we've
never seen
and
we had to reprint the menu we repainted
last year because we did a a coveted
menu
and then we reprinted again
a couple weeks ago and it's coming out
now to
reflect what's happening inflationary
wise i mean scallops
i mean my god the scallops that cost me
250 a gallon that's eight pounds
you know i mean this is nuts you talk
about luxury food
maybe if you you're a stockbroker you
just knocked your [ __ ] on bitcoin you
can afford it but the normal schmove
comes to myrtle beach you who wants a
plate of seafood it's not affordable
what did scallops used to cost you what
did that gallon of scallops used to cost
well i'm going to get some today
the really big ones the u10s and u12s
are costing me between
250 today and then six months ago they
were about 150 160.
wow so
i mean yes it's a very regulated fishery
but
the scallops is a prime example shrimp
is still at a norm it's not like it was
years ago where it was a luxury food
because we import more than what we
process here in america
but that's why we had to reprint the
menu
ted what's it gonna take to have an
actual return
to normalcy and are we talking months or
years
well well
looking at the big picture
once the pandemic hit and the american
labor started getting those 920
checks per week
and if then from there it kept getting
extended in another extension
and then there was
extended unemployment which is still
happening today
so what it did was not only
create a superfluous society of
complacency but all of a sudden where's
the american worker
that 10 hour worker
now wants 15 or else he'll go to the
hill and he's starting people at 17.
the hospitality industry is the one that
suffered the biggest that i can see
the specialized trades
they're not so much but i mean they're
all hurting for people for bodies
so between all that
during the pandemic times yeah
they had money for expendable goods but
did they want to come back to work no
until it's absolutely necessary
now
again looking at the big picture you've
got your labor your basic labor
who
working for you for years for say for 12
13 an hour
now he wants 17 or else he walks all
right so you've got to make concessions
right and throw that in with
250 a gallon scallops
and four dollars and 20 cents there was
this morning
gasoline
we have to sustain as well
you know and and then again there's an
expression you don't you don't make
money in your business on a daily basis
you make it on a yearly basis
well during that year you still have to
survive
you got to pay your bills you got to pay
your taxes
you got to pay your unemployment taxes
my god my workman's comp
almost doubled my auto i'm running four
autos
uh two refrigerated trucks the bus and
then and a pickup
on the road and that's 8 500 a year in
insurance
vehicle insurance
i mean we were normally paying 2 800.
you see
and so everything is commensurate
it's great
we wish you a lots of continued success
in the long run ted hammerman otherwise
known as mr fish
in myrtle beach south carolina thank you
so much for your time i want to leave
something with the listeners you can't
remember you can't live on wishes but
you can live on fishes
ted thank you so much
thank you
[Music]
download fox news channels the five
podcast for free five of your favorite
fox news personalities discuss current
issues in a round table discussion get
it now on apple podcasts google play and
foxnewspodcasts.com
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
a trip to a famed jersey shore
restaurant sent one couple home with
more than just leftovers michael
stressler and his wife maria have been
going to the lobster house since the 80s
and during a recent visit he says he
grew concerned when he felt something
hard in his food
nj.com reports that michael was having
his usual appetizer of a dozen oysters
on the half shell complete with a little
hot sauce cocktail sauce and lemon
when he thought one of his teeth had
cracked
it turned out to be a perfectly round
white pearl instead
his wife says she'd like to keep the
pearl which measures almost nine
millimeters across and maybe have it set
in a ring or a necklace but michael says
he's more interested in finding out what
it's worth he says nothing like this has
ever happened to him before and he's
been told it could be worth thousands of
dollars depending on the body of water
it came from
good luck michael tanya j powers fox
news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
carol markowitz
what's on your mind everyone remembers
the last activities they did before the
world shut down in march 2020.
mine was attending my friend's beautiful
wedding in aruba and hearing from family
back home that all the activities around
the jewish holiday of purim had been
cancelled
i wasn't shocked that the pandemic was
hitting our shores
a month earlier my brother-in-law who
lives in asia was sending pictures of
the temperature check to get into his
office building we're all going to get
this thing he told us
we got home from the wedding pulled our
kids from school and went straight into
lockdown
while we reminisce on the before times
it's equally important to recall the
beliefs that had been shattered by these
two coven 19 years i was a small
government conservative sure but i
somehow still believed in our health
agencies
i was certain our health officials had
spent decades preparing for a pandemic
such as this they would lead the way on
sharing information between countries
carefully discarding information from
totalitarian regimes like china and
would prioritize returning us to normal
as soon as possible
in retrospect it's crazy that i had such
faith
i didn't think i was naive but it turns
out i was i was raised on the ronald
reagan quote the nine most terrifying
words in the english language are i'm
from the government and i'm here to help
end quote and still i believed this was
important this was their moment to shine
they couldn't let us down now
they did not shine they did let us down
from locking us all down to frequently
providing conflicting information and
lying that the quote science had quote
changed our health agencies were
complete disaster
the leaders at the agencies dr rochelle
wallensky at the centers for disease
control and prevention or dr anthony
fauci at the national institutes of
health either straight out bungled any
task or comment or simply lied to us
this isn't about the fog of the pandemic
the spring of 2020 this is to the
present day
as late as november 2021 wallenski was
alleging that masking was at least 80
percent effective in stopping all
viruses
that would be miraculous if true it is
not true
there has not been a single study that
showed masking to be an effective way of
stopping covet 19 let alone the common
cold
and yet right now in new york city
toddlers are masked because of the
broken and unscientific policies pushed
by these organizations
fauci would go on tv and be led along by
the interviewer in an april 2021
interview with savannah guthrie on the
today show guthrie asked about the
recent loosening of masking guidance and
why her child still had to mask
according to guidance while she did not
fauci assured her that children would
get vaccinated soon and would be able to
unmask then
but here's the kicker there was no new
guidance exempting children from
removing their masks outdoors
guthrie had gotten it wrong and fauci
simply went along with it both fauci and
wolenski would destroy the faith
americans like me had in our health
agencies they did not conduct themselves
or the agencies to the benefit of us all
only to the benefit of their political
allies americans will never again simply
follow what health agencies tell them we
need agencies to tell us the truth in
times of crisis
we need agencies that reach sane and
rational conclusions and don't foment
hysteria these agencies are not what we
have
this is carol markowitz
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to everyone talks to
liz fox business's liz clayman talks
with entrepreneurs and executives about
inspiring and motivational stories
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
[Music]